[Music]
in normal public news nom all terribly
I'm not permitted by bare bum ah public
school students in Arizona now eligible
for a scholarship program their health
runs a private school tuition Oh howdy
y'all so normal public school now it's
just like a quick baby title there's no
public school so a lot of teachers are
saying that this is the beginning to the
end of public school
what do you mean how tell me today there
okay so little details it make my song
rock and I love it I wrong address the
way no single [ __ ] winner in the
whole thing [ __ ] committed all
the way through the back wing I've been
the bottom I saw evidence really shot us
my goal right so all public school
students are now eligible in Arizona are
now as eligible for an empowerment
scholarship accounts program the women
wings needed to meet requirements which
were to be disabled foster students
active-duty military kids Native
American kids or those attending failing
schools that used to be the requirements
but now it's open to all students and so
with this fun you can go to a private
school so it doesn't doing is allowing
parents to use their child share of
states educated funding to pay for
private school tuition home schooling
cause tutoring and online education as
well as therapies for the disabled it
does sound really cool but there's also
a lot of people against it because what
are they saying
because it just sounds like paradise so
what critics are saying is that this
will drain more money from underfunded
schools or
schools and it will cost taxpayers way
more money they're also saying that this
will eventually lead to the demise of
the public education school system in
total they're also saying that the
amount of money in the accounts given to
these students are too little for
low-income students to afford
high-quality private education and so
they're saying that the main people that
will benefit off of this is wealthy
parents that will just use that public
money like money for public schools to
fund their cut their child education and
then they could just pay the extra so
they're kind of getting like a discount
is if you already have money exactly
people who already have money though
that money part doesn't mean anything to
them I think that's the perspective of a
poor person yeah that's what Democrats
are saying so then Republicans are
saying that this is a good thing because
this allows children from low-income
families to escape failing public
schools blood Fitz has already been
proven false because there's been a
study showing that 75% of participants
have gone they came from good school so
it does yeah I mean I've said this on
this channel multiple times before money
doesn't solve these type of issues it
all starts at the home and I'm telling
you because I worked at at school
programs like you cannot throw money at
kids who do not find a value in
education it doesn't work our family
parents make a stupid tail or that's
exactly what it is so it's like
after-school programs have been some of
the most effective [ __ ] because you give
them a place where they can come and it
kind of creates a positive environment
this stuff it doesn't [ __ ] work like
I'm telling you if you've ever worked
with kids especially like disadvantaged
youth it doesn't work you tell a kid
like you I'll give you this this and
that
if you read this book I'm going to [ __ ]
about this [ __ ] because they don't give
a [ __ ] about it so this idea it doesn't
work it doesn't [ __ ] work and it's
been proven that it doesn't work I don't
understand why people still don't get
you give me more books I'm going to tag
in them so another thing that supporters
are saying is that this works best for
parents with disabled students and
especially because these these students
they don't get those resources needed in
public school we can get that
private schools because there could be
like disabled private schools or
something and then they can send their
kids to that special place yeah oh
that's not like a sort of smart time I
deal with they're coming from though so
there's already a huge disparity in like
public schools in a good area in a
public school in the shitty area and
then you have people that are going to
like I guess a really good private
school so the disparity of education is
so crazy I think they're just thinking
how can we kind of live it up level the
playing field a little bit and if we
give some of the people in a bad area
some money maybe they can send some of
their kids into the private school area
actually I think it would be better for
them to put that money into a system or
you make it accessible for people who
are already in underprivileged area
first is having to send the brightest
people to an already smart area you know
what I mean like focus on these
underprivileged like underfunded areas
and even sounds like though it sounds
like the Republicans are the more
wealthy people they're telling the less
wealthy people hey here's your chance to
send your kids to my kids school I know
he sunsets exact opposite what I'm
saying don't spread them there put those
here you know so you open you to make
such shitty schools better better and
you put that into those programs and
you're open are my crackers exactly so
that's that's the smartest thing to do
David's a Democrat and parts a
Republican I think it's I think it's
tough though it's hard to like you know
that kind of going back with what you're
saying it's like if it starts out the
family so like usually when you're in a
shitty neighborhood like let's say all
10 of the families don't really give a
[ __ ] about school and maybe nine out of
ten don't give a [ __ ] about school there
is that one family that does care about
school it's going to be easier to send
that one kid to a nicer school and then
he he at least gets what he wants
then to change the entire school system
but you still got nine other families
I'm not talking about you in the whole
school system I'm talking about adding a
supplemental program a social opponent
do it after school and those things do
work 100% so instead of like having to
take up and flip the whole world you
leave it open to all these kids and they
don't have to fight for these
but if it's already there those kids can
go it's kind of like um the YMCA or at
Boys & Girls
yeah you know what I mean and I think
they work really really well but they
keep on trying to take some of the
brightest students and put them in
already affluent areas and that's not
what needs to be in my opinion anyways
from what I've seen you know cuz I think
those - those kids - they still need to
be there because there still has to be
people who set examples in that school
and you take away the brightest students
from these schools that's not there you
know that's all true yeah so they're
saying that the average size of an
account for like per student this is
average because there's like a range the
average is 5,700 a year for children
without disabilities and 9,000 dollars
for children with disabilities so that's
how much money will be put into these
account for the parents to Pirlo student
or whatever for their parents to decide
what they want to do with that money for
their kids education yeah and so they
say that the funds are distributed via a
debit card
that's dope but a private school is way
more than that some private schools are
like 12 17 G's a year as we gather in
the point of the Democrats so they're
saying that private school tuition be
very butta ranges from $5,000 to $17,000
of 0 yeah and it's like a college
tuition and just just because you say
private school doesn't mean that
education is going to be better there's
a lot of private Christian schools out
there that are up to par with the
standards of regular even the worst
public schools because they like to
receive our money it know they like to
withhold certain information like they
don't want to teach evolution or they
don't want to teach certain things so
you know there's that argument too just
because you go to a private school
doesn't mean that your kids going to go
become smarter or have more attention or
all that stuff I mean is there a
requirement for you to get into private
school like you would have to take a
test pow pow pow wow so it's money and
then depending on which private school
you go to they assess the student and
they get to decide we want to or we
don't hey what are those schools were
those genius kids go to magnet magnet
school
magnet school or there's another name
for it because because those schools too
like there's certain people that pay a
certain amount of tuition for it and
there's also they also head hunt for
genius kids too so they could pay for
their tuition so they can develop yeah I
think that's really good because I feel
like a lot of genius kids they can't do
well and regular traditional schools
because I get picked on and [ __ ] up
and all kinds of stuff or you know they
just don't fit in and they feel weird
but if they get it in with group of
people that that are like-minded you
know they'll feel like a comfort and
safety around them I can see that we had
a kid that was like really smart but he
got picked on a lot because it was
probably socially stupid yeah and of
mine in college he went to a magnet
school and he says like the way they
teach there was way different because
they teach them how to problem solve
instead of like giving them answers
instead of a guru today yeah so they
have they figure out their own
methodology for how having the salty
even with like mathematics problems so
when I would see him like even what we
want to Riverside he didn't do well
because it was so structured you know I
don't do well yeah so it was hard for
him but then like for example when he
got an SDK that both sought out that the
clutch was [ __ ] up he just
disassembled the whole car they put it
back together he fisted himself like
that's how his mind works
yeah do you I think you're going to be
putting your kid in private school for
me I don't really care about public or
private I just want the school to align
with my ideals with beliefs and Alessa
I think we're ready to have a ready to
take our kids to school I probably want
to go into every school and when I talk
to the faculty see like what their
teaching style is what the curriculum is
and stuff like that really get to
understand the school because I think
like jealousy some private schools
actually aren't that good because
ultimately every single school is funded
somehow right so private schools the
money comes directly from the parents
paychecks public schools that comes from
property tax which is why the more
affluent neighborhoods like something
like Beverly Hills or San Marino if
every home is two million dollars to 2%
or 3% whatever the property taxes across
two million dollars there's a [ __ ] ton
of money going into schools like that
programs are the best their band is the
best the art if it's like every single
program is the best you go in the hood
no one owns a house everything is a
project right then there is no property
taxes are completely under so they're
unknown so if you go to a jeweler like a
place like San Marino or they just have
like way more money than University
there yeah it's probably way more
probably way more better funded when you
put it like a private school like in a
regular city I went to a public school
by the way
wait mo bettah buncher niversity
edumacated but my English is constipated
tailback this better recording the
English language single-handedly by
himself mother in the new generation do
I be getting [ __ ] message hey what's
up mutter David I'm like [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I get like mother inspo what a
dislike then I'm like what yeah we're
this Amy I'm trained Martha I don't care
let the world use it you know I think
it's an urban dictionary tapenade Maura
I want to going on dick a news fans hope
you guys like in that episode remember
to follow our personal social media and
of course if you want to watch more
videos my I should go where to go you're
suckers right up there
[Music]